CBS News legal analyst Jonathan Turley
is a constitutional law professor at
George Washington University and joins
us at the table good to see you thank
you
so you know William Barr personally I
want to get your take on him because a
couple of eyebrows are being raised that
he made this decision that there is no
that there's no obstruction in less than
two days do you move too quickly maybe I
don't think that's true I think that
quite frankly I don't know any
prosecutor that would bring this case
into an actual court of law would be two
years ago I I did and the fact is that
it's very hard actually to obstruct
something that is not an underlying
crime now President Trump made a really
good effort at that I mean he almost
counterpunched his way into a
obstruction case but it's very difficult
what bars saying is that it's not
impossible you can actually still
obstruct something that was an original
crime but in this case there's really
not the facts for that he has other
defenses to make this is not in my view
a closed case on obstruction to
determine obstruction would you have to
no intent ant in no intent would you've
had to have a thorough interrogation of
the president that was not that wasn't
that wasn't had in this case I think if
there was an underlying crime of
collusion that issue would loom more
significantly but I don't think this was
a particularly close call either for bar
or Rosenstein I think that they looked
at this and said look no no prosecutor
would likely take this obstruction case
now having said that that doesn't mean
that he's exonerated you know the
standard for presidents shouldn't be hey
look I actually wasn't indicted of
felonies I mean we tried to reach a
slightly higher standard than that so
the fact is much of what the President
did was highly inappropriate and
arguably acts of obstruction but did he
fall short of that line yeah I think he
fell short by some distance all right
well we're on torciano time John thank
you so much for helping us out here at
Jonathan Turley thank you